hey Vsauce Michael here now one of my
favorite treats of the holiday season is
Gabriel's cake it's a super solid based
on Gabriel's horn that you can make
right at home as long as your home is
infinitely large okay all right now the
first thing you want to do is bake a
cake I prepared this cake earlier it's a
real beautiful cake it's a little large
but I bet you I could eat that whole
thing in a day if I tried all right okay
now the second step is cut the cake in
half notice that while I cut this cake
in half you don't add or create any new
cake but the surface area of the cake
has increased it used to be completely
covered and now we've got two regions on
the inside that aren't covered the next
step is to cut this half one of the
halves in half here we go again the
volume of cake on the table is the same
as it was in the beginning but the
surface area is going up as you may be
able to guess the next step is going to
be to cut one of these corners of the
original cake in half oh yeah it's
getting pretty thin but all you have to
do is keep this up cutting halves in
half and half and half and half forever
and once you've done that well you're
almost there when you finish cutting
stack the halves on top of one another
in order like this to create a beautiful
tiered dessert because you have an
infinite number of thinner and thinner
slices when you're done stacking them
the cakes vertical height will be
endless such a cake has an interesting
mathematical property its volume the
amount of cake it contains is clearly no
different than the amount you started
with but its surface area is infinite
it's a cake you can eat but not frost
you would
need an infinite amount of frosting to
cover the whole thing with a uniform
coat an object with finite volume but
infinite surface area doesn't need to be
endlessly tall by the way there are
bound in super solids like this cube
with an infinite number of smaller and
smaller circular holes of course
building these objects in the real world
comes with some obvious difficulties one
is the fact that the amount of steps
required to complete the construction of
gabriel's cake or any other super solid
is literally infinitely many and
infinity isn't a number that you know
you eventually get to it means unending
there will always be a next step another
piece to slice in half again by
definition an infinite sequence of tasks
has no last task so you could never
finish making a super solid or could you
enter the super task
what if instead of taking the same
amount of time to complete each step we
accelerated as we worked and did each
step in half the time as the last for
example let's say you want to make
Gabriel's cake in just two minutes oh
that's easy
first cut the original cake in half and
then wait a minute before making the
second cut wait half a minute before
making the third a quarter of a minute
before the fourth and so on always
waiting for half of what's left to pass
before cutting again since you can keep
dividing in half forever there will
always be another step infinite actions
within a finite amount of time is a
super task
the strange thing of course is that
while super tasking no matter how many
steps you've already completed there
will always be an infinite amount of
steps ahead but yet when times up you
will have finished all of them what
we've just described is similar to xenos
famous paradox of the dichotomy in which
the Greek hero Achilles runs a short
race that he can clearly finish
I mean people finish races all the time
but how exactly it's finished is a
mystery because first Achilles must
cover half of the races distance and
then half of what's left and half again
and again and again since there will
always be another halfway point to reach
the number of subdivisions is infinite
there is no final destination after
which Achilles his next stop is the
finish line but yet Achilles obviously
can finish he somehow reaches them all
despite the fact that during his journey
he always has an infinite number of
steps left to reach think about it this
way what if at each halfway step along
the way Achilles is required to hold up
a flag at even steps a blue flag and at
odd steps a red flag blue red blue red
read the flags will alternate faster and
faster but when Achilles finishes the
race which flag will he be holding up to
be holding up either flag would seem to
suggest that a largest number not only
exists but is either even or odd now to
this it is often suggested that the real
problem here is that Achilles isn't
actually doing infinitely many things
he's just taking a few strides or
whatever a true super task requires
doing infinitely many distinct actions
fair enough
but even if Achilles ran the race in a
staccato fashion stopping at each
halfway point for half as long as he
waited at the last one the scenario
would still be sensible and logical and
would complete in a finite amount of
time it has even been shown how a
staccato runner could move to avoid
discontinuous velocities and
accelerations the point is fine infinite
distinct actions are at least logically
possible to do in a finite amount of
time but only logically only as a
mathematical abstraction super tasks are
obviously just products of our
imagination because in the real world
there must be some smallest amount of
space and/or time that cannot be
meaningfully divided in half again once
you're within one of these distances of
the finish line the only possible next
position you can have is the finish line
that certainly seems fair
after all it's believed that in reality
there is a smallest meaningful distance
the Planck length any interactions
between or observations of particles
more accurate than this span make no
sense within physics as we understand it
today and the time it would take to
travel a Planck length at the fastest
speed possible the speed of light is the
Planck time
so these seem to be the briefest pieces
of space and time any known force in the
universe could act across whether that
forces gravity or a force from Achilles
leg muscles but does that resolve the
crisis or is it just a way of avoiding
the problem altogether by saying it
doesn't matter because it won't be on
the test
as John Airmen has complained it seems
to me unattractive to make the truth of
mathematical statements depend on the
contingencies of space-time structure
maybe xenos dichotomy tells us less
about motion and time and space and
truth than it does about our impressive
abilities to confuse ourselves and
that's what makes super tasks important
they're a contact point an uneasy
handshake of sorts between the universe
we live in and the brains inside us
let's play around with some they're not
all the same
some converge like xenos dichotomy
others converge but in ways you may not
expect and still others refuse to
cooperate in any way they diverge a
great example of a super task whose
behavior diverges is Thompson's lamb a
famous super task devised by James F
Thompson imagine a lamp that can be
turned on and off as quickly as you
desire what would happen if you turn to
such a lamp on and off Z knowingly well
let's find out just set a timer and turn
the lamp on then wait one minute and
turn it off after half a minute turn it
back on and then off again after a
quarter of a minute on again after an
eighth of a minute and so on waiting
half as long to flip the switch each
time as you previously did now as the
number of switchings grows without bound
the total time elapsed approaches just
two minutes the lamp will be turned on
ah an infinite number of times in just
two minutes so after two minutes will
the lamp be on or off
well by the definition of infinity there
is no last step there is never a
switching not followed by another so the
lamp can't be on because whenever it's
turned on it is immediately turned off
in the next step and it can't be off
because whenever it's turned off its
turned on right afterwards what's the
answer it's easy to say something about
a super task when it's partial sums
converge but when they just oscillate
back and forth forever hmm xeno objects
do this imagine building a meter high Q
as with all super tasks you construct at
an accelerated pace first you put down a
green half metre tall slab then a
quarter meter tall slab that's orange
then a green 8 meter slab than an orange
sixteenth meter slab and so on until
there are infinitely many layers of
alternating color now when you look at
the cube from above what color will you
see orange green but it can't be orange
because every orange layer is covered by
a green one and it can't be green
because every green layer is blocked by
an orange one above it what if we had a
machine display each digit of Pi in
order at a super task pace after its
finite run time what would be on the
screen the last digit of pi well that's
impossible right but how could it be
anything else a super task allows us to
exhaust an infinite sequence Paul Vince
are off delivered what is often
considered the best response to these
confusions is Thompson's lamp on or off
is the cube orange or green the answer
is we don't know because these questions
are incomplete Thompson's lamp could be
on or off or broken the cube could
appear orange or
green or something else but the super
tasks as stated don't let us figure out
which I may as well ask you if a lamp
hidden in a locked room is on or off
it's definitely one or the other but I
haven't given you enough information to
do anything but guess super tasks like
these describe an endless sequence of
tasks and then ask us about the end but
we can't determine an outcome because
although there may be an end to their
duration there is no end no final member
of their actions they must be reworded
or coupled with extra assumptions in
order to be solved for example if we
assume that the switch used on
Thompson's lamp can only be all the way
on or all the way off we can't determine
where it is after the super task but if
the switch is say a bouncing ball that
completes the circuit turning the lamp
on each time it bounces on a metal plate
an outcome can be determined if the
physics here are ideal and the ball
bounces half as high in half the time as
it did on the previous bounce its
sequence of Bounce heights will turn the
lamp on and off an infinite number of
times in a finite amount of time
although this bouncing ball has no
penultimate state no second-to-last
bounce it does have an ultimate state a
final one resting on the plate the
circuit will be complete and the lamp
will be on you can also describe a
switch on Thompson's lamp that leaves it
off
sometimes the next state after
infinitely many isn't paradoxical
because of lack of information but
because of a surprising or non-intuitive
discontinuity that occurs there the ross
littlewood paradox is one of the
greatest examples imagine a giant urn
that can hold an unlimited number of
balls now imagine that you have an
unlimited supply of balls each with a
unique natural number written on it all
natural numbers in fact since there is
no end to how many balls you have now
working at an accelerated xeno Ian Paice
you move the balls to the urn 10 at a
time but in a weird way at step one you
place balls number one to 10 in the urn
but remove number one at step two a
minute later you place balls 11 to 20 in
the urn and remove ball number two at
step three you place Paul's 21 to 30 in
the urn and remove ball three and so on
upon the completion of the super task
how many balls will be in the urn at
first the answer seems obvious at each
step you are adding 10 balls and
subtracting one so a net of nine balls
is added each time 9 plus 9 plus 9 plus
9 forever the series grows without end
infinite nines means infinite balls at
the end but here's the problem at each
step the ball with that steps number
written on it is removed ball 1 is
removed at step 1 ball 2 is removed at
step 2 ball 12 Google is removed at step
12 Google since there are an endless
number of steps for any ball number
there is a step number at which it is
removed
so although the urns ball population
grows without bound during the task
after the super task the number drops to
zero
it gets weirder here's a second
seemingly identical method instead of
beginning with balls one to ten and then
removing one begin with balls one to
nine then right zero after the one on
ball one for step two add balls 11 and
19 and draw a zero on ball two
making it say 20 for every finite step
both methods result in identical urn
contents but after infinitely many steps
the first leaves us with no balls and
the second leaves us with infinitely
many balls written on which are all the
natural numbers each followed by an
infinite string of zeros both are
discontinuous at infinity but dang in
very different ways the bigger question
now becomes so what who cares you will
never have an infinite number of balls
and you will never have a large enough
urn to hold all of them you will never
build a lamp that can turn on and off
arbitrarily fast
we cannot investigate time or space past
a certain smallness except when
pretending so what are super tasks but
recreational fictions entertaining
riddles we can ask more questions than
we can answer so what well here's what
Neanderthals Neanderthals and humans us
Homo sapiens lived together in Europe
for at least 5,000 years
Neanderthals were strong and clever they
may have even intentionally buried their
dead but for hundreds of thousands of
years
Neanderthals barely went anywhere they
pretty much just explored and spread
until they reached water or some other
obstacle and then stopped
Homo sapiens on the other hand didn't do
that they did things that made no sense
crossing terrain and water without
knowing what lay ahead
Svante Paabo has worked on the
neanderthal genome at the Max Planck
Institute for evolutionary anthropology
and he points out that technology alone
didn't allow humans to go to Madagascar
to Australia
Neanderthals built boats too instead he
says there's quote some madness there
how many people must have sailed out and
vanished on the Pacific before you found
Easter Island I mean it's ridiculous and
why do you do that is it for the glory
for immortality for curiosity and now we
go to Mars we never stop it's ridiculous
foolish maybe but it was the
Neanderthals who went extinct not the
humans maybe it's only a fool who will
perilously journey out to what might not
be there and maybe it's only a fool who
will ask about super tasks about
infinity but if you want to solve
problems you don't just solve the ones
that are there you find more and make
more and go after the impossible ones
fostering a love and obsession with
problems is how you solve problems
Antoine de saint-exupéry wasn't a
mathematician but his advice fits nicely
here if you want to build a ship don't
drum up people to collect wood and don't
assign them tasks and work but rather
teach them to long for the endless
immensity of the sea and as always
thanks for watching
super tasks are cool but super gifts are
even cooler that's why I'm excited to
announce this year's Vsauce holiday box
this thing comes loaded with exclusive
Vsauce stuff and science gear plus all
Vsauce proceeds go directly to
Alzheimer's research I'm really proud of
this box you can pick one up at geekfuel
comm slash Vsauce link down in the
description there's a limited amount
available so don't hesitate and as
always thanks for watching